hello everyone and welcome to today
presentation development of multiplex
xMAP technology-based assays for
simultaneous detection of soluble
checkpoint molecules involved in
anti-cancer immunity response presented
by Suzanne Euler manager research and
development antibodies and amino acids
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
please visit
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Suzanne Euler I will now turn the
presentation over to her
Thank You Alexis in today's talk I will
be presenting a poster about development
of multiplex xMAP technology bit based
essays for the simultaneous detection of
soluble checkpoint molecules involved in
anti-cancer immune response but first I
would like to give you some background
information about two more in you know
technology our immune system has evolved
to protect the integrity of
multicellular organisms against external
threats such as pathologic organisms on
the one hand but also against malignant
cells that I've generated in cancer
Genesis during cancer Genesis genetic
and epigenetic alterations of the cells
occur which the immune system can use to
distinguish tumor cells from their
normal counterparts T cells and NK cells
are important players in fighting
malignant cells harnessing the power of
the immune system to find cancer is a
therapeutic approach which is very
successful for certain cancer types and
individual patients many new anti-cancer
therapies aiming to engage the power of
the new system to combat cancer are
under investigation
however tumor cells also acquire escape
mechanisms to avoid being attacked by
the immune system which may lead to
immune resistance under physiological
conditions the activity of immune cells
needs to be strictly controlled to
ensure the immune systems balance
between the recognition of non-self and
the prevention of autoimmunity this
regulation involves proteins referred to
as immune checkpoints which can affect
in you know regulatory pathways by
either boosting or restricting the
immune response
here you see the cans immunity psycho is
proposed by Chen and Melman this psycho
describes how the immune system reacts
to malignant cells and the interactions
that take place between immune cells and
tumor cells I will walk you through this
cycle let us begin with number one which
is below
so Tamar sell antique antigens so called
neo antigens are released to the
microenvironment the new your antigens
of Earth phagocytosed by antigen
presenting cells like dendritic cells
which present the new antigen and
migrate to the lymph node in the lymph
node the newer antigens are presented to
T cells the T cells get primed and
activated and start proliferate the
activated T cells migrate via via blood
vessels to the tumor and infiltrate the
tumor this is called extravasation the
activated T cells recognize their target
in the tumor via the T cell receptor
this is shown in number six and finally
the cancer cell gets killed by cytotoxic
T cells this is in step number seven and
the killing of the cancer cells lead to
further release of more new antigens now
we are at number one again plus this
leads to a propagation of the new immune
response each step of this cycle
requires the coordinated
coordination of numerous vectors both
stimulatory and inhibitory in nature
stimulatory vectors are shown in green
here promote immunity various inhibitors
shown in red reduce immune activity to
avoid over activation of the immune
system causing damage to healthy cells
these regulating factors may be
cytokines factors released by dying
tumor cells and the microbiota and
checkpoint molecules it is important to
note that not only tumor cells but also
other cell types of the immune system
like infra tumor or T regulatory cells
mark
of Ages and Malory derived suppressor
cells are sources of inhibitory factors
if the inhibitory factors outweigh the
stimulatory factors the tumor can escape
the hosts immune response the goal of
immunotherapy is to initiate or re
initiate a self-sustaining cycle of
cancer immunity enabling it to amplify
and propagate but not so much as to
generate unrestrained autoimmunity
immune inflammatory responses
immune checkpoint molecules are
recognized as intact trans main proteins
however soluble isoforms or shed
variants have been identified for the
majority of these molecules these
soluble checkpoint molecules are either
generated by shedding from the membrane
via proteases predominantly atom
proteases or they are generated as
soluble variants by alternative splicing
soluble checkpoint molecules may
function as immune adjuvant or decoy
receptors and they may thereby regulate
the checkpoint pathways to provide a
tool for the measurement of circulating
soluble checkpoint molecules we
developed a pro cataplexy panel which is
based upon luminix beads technology for
the targets the targets you see listed
here in this slide high plasma
concentration of these soluble molecules
may interfere with the efficiency of
cancer therapies using antibodies
against checkpoint moderators of t-cells
in addition to the important role of the
adaptive immunity
also innate immune cells especially NK
cells contribute to anti-cancer immune
response the major role of NK cells is
to recognize virus infected cells which
show alterations on their cell surface
in analogy NK cells can also recognize
and attack transformed malignant cells
lacking MHC class 1 in addition to MHC
class 1 deficiency and k cell activity
is mediated by multiple activating and
inhibitory receptors which determine if
in case L becomes cytotoxic here you see
the receptors and ligands either on the
tumor cell or on the NK cell activated
NK cells can act directly by a
preference which disrupts the target
cell membrane in addition NK cells may
also act indirectly
by secreting pore inflammatory cytokines
thereby stimulating adaptive immune
response such as T cell response
activating receptors of NK cells
described so far are NK g 2 d NC R and T
G M 1 which can act in a synergistic way
ligands 2 n k GT do
like Mick a McBee and you l16 binding
proteins are upregulated in cellular
stress response and expressed by many
tumor cells however during tumor
progression cancer cells developed
immunosuppressive mechanisms that
circumvent NK cell mediated killing
shedding soluble ligands for NK cell
activating receptors is a mechanism
tumor cells used to escape immuno
surveillance therefore similarly as
fatty cells immunity robotic agents are
under investigation for NK cells to
stimulate their life lytic capacity and
support them to recognize and eradicate
tumors the major in case of receptors
that are potential in you know
therapeutics in you know therapeutic
targets are shown in this slide here and
here on the next slide
you have receptors and ligands from NK
cells which can be measured with our
immune oncology checkpoint panel tool on
this slide the targets are listed for
example the soluble forms of the already
mentioned McKay and might be both immuno
oncology checkpoint panels can be
combined and also extended with
cytokines chemokines and the TG
molecules which encounter another
important role in shaping local and
systemic immune responses variety I
tokens have been demonstrated to be
associated with chronic inflammation
which may promote cancer development or
with acute inflammation which
facilitates cancer rejection the
simultaneous direction of immune
stimulatory and the inhibitory factors
allows to gain a more holistic picture
of the molecular players in canes
immunity and should help to shed light
on the biology of the pathways is show
first results of our customers using
these panels in the next slides I will
show you some examples from our
customers this data you see here was
generated by one of our beta tester
using both immuno oncology checkpoint
panels in combination as samples sera
from melanoma patients were analyzed for
all targets of both panels measured
levels are shown here the levels are
shown as mean values of about 70 to 90
samples
as you can see there were detectable
levels for soluble checkpoint marker
proteins in these samples
here the next example shows the effect
of treatment on one of these targets the
samples are grouped in pretreatment
which you see on the left and early on
treatment on the right and the mean pd-1
level is shown for each group during
treatment the mean serum concentration
of pd-1
decreases strongly as you can see
you
here you see the levels of individual
patients for every patient the PD PD one
level before treatment this is shown in
blue during treatment shown in red it's
shown here so as you can see the levels
of the individual samples differed
strongly this data are promising but
preliminary and it will be very
interesting to combine the data obtained
with clinical outcome of therapy
here you see data obtained with our
immune oncology panel during beta
testing which is already published by
our beta tester the detected levels of
several checkpoint markers in samples
from human breast cancer patients before
before and after chemotherapy are shown
six immune checkpoint molecules were
detected with high level in these
samples interestingly CD 27c dat and CD
273 correlated with the HMG b1 level and
were increased in human samples with a
better response to APO beads in dogs
attack cell chemotherapy and abet the
five-year survival
time-dependent changes of specific
soluble checkpoint molecules can be seen
here in our last example this data is
obtained by measurement we did in house
with samples which were provided by our
Peto tester in this study the immune
oncology panel in combination with the
tariff receptor superfamily panel was
used to measure samples taken at
different time points during therapy as
an example the data for CD 27 is shown
on the left and on the right side you
have the data for CD 30 while CD 27
levels were very consistent over time
for a series 30 there was an increase at
the beginning of their treatment which
went down again during treatment
in addition to our pocket obliques in
Yunnan college teaching checkpoint
marker panels we also have developed
Eliza's for immune oncology target these
available
Eliza's are listed on this slide
our better testing results confirm that
our pocket applix immune oncology
checkpoint mark up a nose can be used to
detect different expression patterns of
soluble markers dependent on disease
state and cancer treatment the
systematic simultaneous analysis of
these soluble biomarkers should help to
shed light on the biology of the
pathways and possibly help to better
understand the response to your cuticle
thank you very much for your attention I
will take any questions now
thank you dr. Euler for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is what is the sample
volume needed for analysis our frozen
samples useful and how many samples can
be analyzed with one kit
the sample value which is needed is 25
micro litre this is enough for measuring
all analytes in combined herbal panels
so it's really not a lot amount which is
needed frozen samples can be used and
with one kit there can be measured up to
80 samples also since we recommend to do
testings in parallel parallel for each
sample it would be then reduced to 40
samples per two kids
now our next question is what is the
sensitivity of your Pro Carter Plex
assays the sensitivity of course is
depending on the individual analyte for
our immune oncology checkpoint marker we
have a low limit of quantification in
the lower picogram per ml range
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
so what can I do if I need to measure
checkpoint markers in mouse models is
your panel cross reacting with the mouse
no as far as we know it doesn't cross
react we did testings with a few
purchased mouse serum pools and these
did not show any level so we we can
assume it's not cross reacting but at
present we have developed or we are at
the end of developing Mouse in Yunnan
ecology targets which will be combined
in two panels we have we will have a
four-plex which contains black 3 Tim 3
PT la and CD 27 and then there will be
another panel a 7 Plex which contains
cdat ctla-4 td1 PDL 1 tier 2 CD 137 l
and d ch3 these both panels will not be
combined able but they can be measured
they can be used as payment to measure
these analyzed
this is what we are going to what we can
provide for mouse analytes
I would like to once again thank dr.
Euler for her presentation I would also
like to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2019 please share
that with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye